I'm not watcher you're a wise and we'll
watch her you watch this chef is going
on I know I don't see you as course
cross over thank you so welcome to the
joint culinary center of excellence this
is where we teach all of the culinary is
and the entire military this was my
station yes this where you put all that
uh that hard work and effort into right
here a lot of love in here I know
there's a lot of stress so we want to
see if you got what it takes to be a
military chef I actually have some
military chef bloodlines you know my dad
used to be a military chef in the Navy
so hopefully I could use some of that
and come out here and be ready to go
I'll head out there to the field kitchen
yeah we're gonna get started to occur
when I actually came in the military I
came in as a nutrition care specialist
so I worked with dietitians in a
hospital but uh I found my passion in
the kitchen you have more control this
way we do this it can peel it off almost
like getting your foot in before you
want you right here want to make sure
you got a solid footing before you go to
make your move but so it's same concept
with your knife you don't want your
knife doing stuff yeah yeah
[Music]
now that we've prepped I'm gonna show
you how I'll do it I think that I got
the best job if you love what you do you
never work a day in your life
[Music]
grab my salmon skin side down when I
joined the military I never thought I
was going to cook with dog collars on a
MKT in the middle for the dinner
it smells so good right now we're on top
in a minute I'm gonna talk to the match
is gonna sink a little bit that's a good
sign
look it to care look at the patients who
don't like big so none you see me do my
demo you got 30 minutes to recreate
exactly what I just did you ready I hope
so that's dumb let's go boom boom man
Bop
chef told me salt you like the ocean Wow
this goes into the bigger bowl right
here think about what's next I'm gonna
go ahead and add a little bit of heavy
cream so wow you got 22 minutes left all
right
but with that bacon on there
Wow I got a little simmer going into the
reduce orange so I spit colonel I lived
canola oil it's a little bit careful not
to get it on the fire hey we're not
curious man with our character I need
some help
Wow carrots different colors nice nice
color choice with the left put a little
more butter now get out of there Go
Daddy the titles are definitely ready
[Applause]
I usually keep one economy all right you
got five minutes left you already on the
plate in
hey guys are nice here a little bit
little extra cheese alright that's a bit
serious can't it just like that
beautiful
all about your eyes three more minutes
to go
was okay
you beat the clock in time you beat the
clock in time your hand with a minute to
spare your question Attalus awesome
people on so as a present our culinary
team here we got to a chef jacket say
thank you for coming out and supporting
us we're at the next one
we're that to the for the practice
facility I'm cooking breakfast tomorrow
everybody eats with their eyes first
right so when I look at you play a
little I see you I see the colors I see
the good sear on a Sandman all the stuff
looks good yeah man this looks terrible
over here man yeah he could nothing
right most people think of the military
they just think about you know our
soldiers that are out there on the
frontlines you know risking their lives
which obviously is a you know huge but
of it don't think about the the people
that are behind it so like yourself that
are feeding and providing you know
nourishment for those guys so I feel
like I have a pretty good like
understanding of how everybody gets fed
what goes into cooking what it takes to
be a chef so it's hard work man I just
want to say thank you for coming out and
working with us man it was an extreme
pleasure to work with you
I really appreciate him coming out here
because they highlights us as chefs but
also like you get to see like all the
support that goes into it and it being a
part of his lineage with families is
really an honor to be here with them and
to take time out of his schedule to come
out here and do this with us this has
been truly an eye-opening experience you
know my first time being on MKT before
learning how military personnel provided
feed other military personnel was pretty
cool being a military brat myself other
question know what we don't for dessert
hey that's on YouTube oh all right